seeing Chairman Mao's little red book  waved in the House of Commons did you  expect to see that unbelievable but they  wave we're back to the Chairman Mao you  know if you what did john lennon say if  you go quick if you if you go creating  chairman mao you ain't gonna make it  with anyone any hard i think it's what  John Lennon said it was subjective can i  really think that they're barking up the  wrong tree I appreciate that there are  they have strong support amongst a  section of of the public I don't think  that they have a credible program in the  economy I think that to attack the  government asleep shadow chancellor  didn't advise that organized for  spending more was absolutely incoherent  since their whole program is to take the  brakes off public spending to whack up  taxation and to cause severe  difficulties for the economy so totally  without credits goes to man